today on the matt walsh show a woman on
a train in philadelphia was sexually
assaulted for nearly 10 minutes while
bystanders watched and did nothing why
does that sort of thing happen and why
does it appear to be so common these
days we'll talk about that also the aclu
files an amicus brief in support of
compelled speech there was a time when
the aclu defended free speech times have
changed though and camilla harris is
campaigning in churches now how can she
walk in the door without bursting into
flames also isn't it illegal to campaign
in churches and finally in our daily
cancellation the outrage mob is very
upset at me because of some things i
said about paternity leave well i
apologize today or double down the
answer may surprise you but probably not
at all all of that and more today on the
matt walsh show
[Music]
so let me ask you something does it make
sense that the same company who controls
half of online retail also passively
eavesdrop drops on your private
conversations at home well big tech is
more powerful than most countries are
and they profit by exploiting your
personal data it's time to put a layer
of protection between your online
activity and big tech and that's why i
use expressvpn think about how much of
your life is on the internet sadly every
site you visit
every video you watch message you send
it all gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something bigtech can use to personally
identify you unless you have expressvpn
so expressvpn makes your activity harder
to trace and sell to advertisers
expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network and expressvpn does all this
without slowing your connection that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by cnet and tech radar so stop
handing over your personal data to the
big tech monopoly that minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself with the vpn that i
trust to keep my my internet activity
safe online visit expressvpn.com
walsh that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn dot com welsh to get
three months free go to go to
expressvpn.comwalsh right now to learn
more
so we begin with a horrific story out of
philadelphia a woman sitting on the
train at 10 pm on wednesday night
was sexually assaulted by a homeless man
the rapist named fistin nagoy sat down
next to the victim tried to touch her
several times she tried to stop him she
pushed back at which point he became
more aggressive and started ripping her
clothes off and this attack went on for
eight minutes
the train was not empty aside from those
two there were other people there there
were other riders in the same car
bystanders bystanders who watched a rape
unfold over the course of nearly 10
minutes and not one of them stepped in
to help the woman
now there are some reports that at least
a few of the onlookers pulled out their
phones and recorded police haven't
confirmed that detail but they have
confirmed that a rape occurred in full
view of a crowd of people and none of
them lifted a finger to help and they
aren't missing words about the
spectators in this case from the new
york times it says quote
i'm appalled by those who did nothing to
help this woman timothy bernhardt the
superintendent of the upper darby
township police department said on
sunday
anybody that was on that train has to
look in the mirror and ask why they
didn't intervene or why they didn't do
something mr nagoy 35 was charged with
rape sexual assault and aggravated
indecent assault without consent among
other crimes court records show the
authority said that he was homeless and
was not armed during the attack several
passengers were in the train car but mr
bernhardt declined to say how many
investigators were still working on to
determine the exact number he said uh he
said while there while there were not
dozens of people in the car at the time
there were enough that quote
collectively they could have gotten
together and done something bystanders
on the train who failed intervene could
be criminally charged if they recorded
the attack mr bernhardt said
now a few things should be said at the
outset first the primary villain in this
case is not the group of useless
bystanders but the perpetrator that
shouldn't need to be said but i say it
anyway because these days the people who
commit these evil acts tend to be
tacitly led off the hook lost in a
shuffle as we debate the circumstances
around the act and what sorts of things
could have been done to stop it and who
should have done whatever those things
are
the rapist is the one responsible in a
serious country would ensure that he
never sees the outside of a prison cell
ever again in his life but we don't live
in that kind of country and philadelphia
is not that kind of city violent crimes
are at record levels in philly right now
as the da's in philadelphia and in the
surrounding districts this crime will be
prosecuted by jack stolsteimer in
delaware county right outside the city
they're all progressive ideologues who
were elected to their positions with the
help of george soros
now this is not a conspiracy theory as
the media likes to portray any mention
of sorrows the minute you mention him
there's a conspiracy theory as if he's a
fictional character
um he's not it is a confirmed fact that
the billionaire the left-wing
billionaire took an interest in
philadelphia district attorney races a
few years ago and he poured millions of
dollars into electing his preferred
candidates
now the city is a brutal violent
hellscape even more than it was before
all this to say that the rapist
homeless and a black man checking
several of the victim boxes
will likely be out on the street again
in no time
and we'll return to that point in just a
moment
with all that said of course the by
standers are still a bunch of weak
gutless cowards cowards again if we
lived in a serious country the rapist
would not have walked out of there
instead of this infuriating and
sickening story we should be reading
about
the inspiring tale of a scumbag who
attempted to lay one hand on a woman and
was summarily beaten unconscious by an
enraged mob of men that's the way it
should have ended
but again that's not the kind of country
we live in and so these kinds of stories
very rarely in that way
we know that violent crimes are often
committed in view of onlookers who could
step in and help but choose not to and
we know that because so often as they
allegedly did in this case the onlookers
elect instead to record the crime on
their phones and that's how we know
about it
yet this problem predates smartphones
we've known about the so-called
bystander effect for a long time and
many famous cases have been documented
through the years
there's always the potential in these
kinds of situations for bystanders to
freeze up fail to act hoping that
somebody else will take care of the
problem
the tendency is so much a part of the
human condition that it made it into the
gospels 2 000 years ago with the parable
of the good samaritan
you know the sole person who stops to
help a man who was beaten by bandits and
left for dead on the side of the road it
is unfortunately a tale as old as time
or at least as old as the human race
this is no excuse for the people in the
crowd who fail to do the right thing
it's just a matter of understanding how
deeply embedded this problem is
though even so
anecdotal evidence like all these videos
that we see all the time would seem to
suggest that the bystander effect is
worse now more prevalent than ever
before people are less willing to put
their necks out less eager to do the
right thing
when doing the right thing may put them
in jeopardy
and they have it would seem far less
shame about their own cowardice
why is that i think that's the important
question
well there are many things many many
contributing factors but let's start
with the fact that unlike years past
the system now actively discourages
people from intervening
i was somewhat annoyed to read those
comments from the local authorities
condemning the onlookers
even though i agree with the
condemnation i agree with
what they said
but
this is partially the fault of those
local authorities
this is partially their fault
with far left da's in office all across
the country and especially especially
all over the philadelphia area
there's no telling what would happen to
somebody if they used physical force to
neutralize an attacker
and that's the case even if you're
defending just yourself
you're defending someone else getting
involved in a situation that didn't that
you were not immediately involved in
who knows i mean if a good samaritan had
stepped up and
given the perpetrator the beat down that
he so desperately deserved
it's not hard to imagine that's that
same good samaritan might face assault
charges the next day
might end up being smeared by the media
as a racist vigilante
this is the exact dilemma that police
officers all over the nation face every
single day and it's their job
and their express legal obligation and
authority to intervene
how much worse could the blowback be for
somebody who doesn't have that express
obligation or authority
whereas in years past a good samaritan
had to only weigh the risk to his own
physical safety before getting involved
now he knows that even if he survives
the encounter his life may still be over
after the fact depending on how it all
plays out and also depending quite
significantly on the racial demographics
involved
now this again is not to provide any
excuses for anybody
we're called to take risks sometimes
very significant risks if we wish to be
decent men
i'm only pointing out that the systems
running this country actively discourage
and punish decency
and besides
many people don't wish to be decent men
in the first place you know as children
were conditioned from a young age to
regard questions of moral decency as
superfluous or even oppressive
the message we absorb from our culture
is that our own physical and
psychological well-being should come
before everything and everybody else
so we we sneer
at moral decency
and we actively punish it
and then we stand back in shock and
horror to find that people are not
decent
we look at the police officer in the
mikaya bryant shooting
he stepped in to stop
a a a girl from getting stabbed to death
and next thing you know people are
calling for his head
lebron james is tweeting out a picture
of him
trying to rile up a mob to go in
who knows what to him
that's the way it goes now
and it reminds me of one of the greatest
lines from one of c.s lewis's greatest
books the abolition of man which if
you've never read you should writing 80
years ago though it might as well have
been yesterday lewis says quote
in a sort of ghastly simplicity we
remove the organ and demand the function
we make men without chess and expect of
them virtue and enterprise we laugh at
honor and are shocked to find traitors
in our midst
we castrate and bid the geldings be
fruitful
that's us
our culture campaigns against virtue and
punishes the virtuous
you can't even go to church anymore to
hear a defense of virtue
we have purposefully created a society
of hollow people
men without chess
and we're surprised by the results
we shouldn't be
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you still haven't picked up the new
book from 40 days for life what to say
when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion i don't know what
you're doing with yourself and your time
especially because i wrote the forward
to that book
and i wrote the four because i i thought
it was a very a good idea for a book a
book that's that's needed you know
which is something that very simply
but also in depth
lays out the arguments
uh against abortion and it kind of lets
you know what what arguments are going
to come right back at you and how to
counter them and so it's a very easy
guide to get through but like i said it
also goes in depth on all of these
arguments since its release it's already
been a number one amazon new release and
a number two amazon bestseller and it's
on its second printing already because
lots of people see that this book is uh
useful and incredibly easy to use it
tells you what to say what not to say
and it's proven arguments that have
worked with everybody people on the
fence abortion supporters even planned
parenthood workers have found these
arguments compelling that's why it's an
invaluable and timely tool so get it
right now what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion go to
amazon or get it directly from 40 days
for life at 40daysforlife.com
okay so
the aclu used to be
an organization that would defend i mean
they had they have civil liberties right
in their name
and they used to defend free speech
that's what that's what they did
and we talked about this before i mean
how
there was a time when the aclu
was so
militant in their defense of free speech
that they would defend
kkk members they would defend
not i mean actual nazis okay they would
defend actual neo-nazis
and defend their free speech
those times are long gone
because there's a case uh in loudoun
county i mean loudoun county has become
the kind of epicenter of many of these
battles in the school system with
critical race theory and with gender
theory
so as you've heard from me on this show
um part of that that policy in loudoun
county where they're opening up the
bathrooms
um to to allow boys into girls bathrooms
even though
a girl was allegedly raped inside of a
bathroom by a boy
uh only just last semester in may
but this is a policy that doesn't just
affect bathrooms and sports teams
also very significantly it requires
teachers to use the preferred pronouns
of um
to use the preferred pronouns of
whatever you know of the students
whatever they say their pronoun is the
teachers have to use it so this is
compelled speech
and it's not just compelling compelled
speech is
bad in and of itself
but what are they being what is the
compelled speech
what what are they being compelled to
affirm they're being compelled to affirm
a falsehood
as a condition of further employment
and not further employment in the
private sector but
in the school
run by the government
so to have a
job in this government building
you have to be willing to affirm
falsehoods
a boy says refer to me as a girl that is
a
confirmed absolute falsehood and the
policy says you have to affirm it or
you're gone
so this is this case is making its way
through the court system
and now we have this from the aclu of
virginia
it says breaking three teachers in
loudoun county are going to court simply
because they don't want to use trans and
nine non-binary students pronouns
we and partners filed an amicus brief to
tell the court
refusing to use a student's pronouns
because of who they are is
discrimination
and then they have their amicus amicus
brief
um
so they're getting out of going out of
their way to involve themselves in this
case
to be on the side of compelling people
to say things
this isn't this is no matter how else
you feel about it
this is without a question an anti-free
speech perspective
even if you think that
you should use the preferred pronouns
that someone
asks you to use or demands that you use
normally
even if that's your position
you can't pretend if you're trying to
force people to do that you can't
pretend that you're on the side of free
speech you're not this is this is
compelled speech
and by the way on the preferred pronouns
thing i just want to read this to you
related to preferred pronouns
here's an article from an entertainment
website called up rocks that i saw
someone shared on
on twitter or something and it jumped
out at me just because of the headline
the headline was so confusing
and i stopped for a second i was trying
to make sense of it
so this is this is a story and i'll read
like just a paragraph from this story in
this entertainment website
about um halsey who i guess is some kind
of pop star
and i also take from context clues that
halsey identifies as non-binary
and her pronouns are she and they
so that's the thing you could do now
you know it's not just that you can
choose to identify as multiple people by
identifying as they them you can
actually identify as both a single
person and multiple people
how do you put all that together in a
sentence if you're talking about someone
well here's uprocks
it says it's been about three months
since halsey gave birth to their first
child and in the day's sense she has
been open about the start of her
parenthood journey in early august they
showed off photos of their postpartum
stretch marks and later that month she
shared her frustrations with how some in
the music industry handled her pregnancy
now halsey is once again pulling the
curtain back this time on their saturday
night live performance and what their
body looks like now
total nonsense
if you had no
no prior knowledge of any of this
pronoun stuff
and you read that paragraph
you you just have simply have no idea
what's being said
halsey is that is that a is that a
person is that a some sort of collective
is that a group
are we talking about two distinct
individuals
where in the span of one sentence we can
change from there to she
but this is if you are teacher in
loudoun county
this is the kind of total nonsense that
you must affirm or lose your job
and the aclu is fully on board with that
this makes it how do you teach
if you're in loudoun county and you're a
english teacher
and you get to the section on grammar
how do you teach grammar anymore it you
can't it's impossible
because this abides by no coherence it's
not that we've changed the rules of
grammar or the rules of grammar have
evolved or any
they're out the window there there
aren't any rules at all this doesn't you
couldn't come up with a new set of rules
to explain
what is happening in that paragraph i
just read
now grammar and language it becomes
totally shapeless and formless
and each person decides for themselves
what a word means
and what the rules of grammar are
and that's a problem you know because
the whole point of language
in a in a human society the whole point
of language is for uh is for a means of
communication
between people
okay so this is a way of language is
it's a way of conveying a message
to somebody else conveying meaning
and in order to do that the reason why
we had in the past anyway we've had laws
rules of grammar
and the reason why there have been these
you know shared definitions and words
have these things called definitions
that we all understand the reason for
that is that there have to be these
shared ground rules in order for me to
understand what the hell you're trying
to tell me
now we're making communication
virtually impossible
all right next let's go to barry weiss
she was uh on with
brian stelter
and i thought that this was an
interesting exchange
as she's trying her best as a barry
weiss by the way is not as far as i know
any kind of right-wing conservative
i imagine her politics are st are
probably pretty liberal
but she's got some basic common sense
and if you have basic common sense
you're going to be exiled from the left
wing no matter what your politics are
that's what's happened with barry weiss
and uh so here she is this person with
common sense trying to speak to
uh brian stelter somebody with with no
common sense whatsoever and here's how
that exchange went
you write there are tens of millions of
americans who aren't on the hard left or
the hard right who feel the world has
gone mad so in what ways has the world
gone mad
well you know when you have the chief
reporter on the beat of kovid for the
new york times talking about how
questioning or pursuing the question of
the lab leak is racist the world has
gone mad
when you're not able to say out loud and
in public that there are differences
between men and women the world has gone
mad when we're not allowed to
acknowledge that rioting is rioting and
it is bad and that silence is not
violence but violence is violence the
world has gone mad when we're not able
to say that hunter biden's laptop is a
story worth pursuing the world has gone
mad when in the name of progress young
school children as young as kindergarten
are being separated in public schools
because of their race and that is called
progress rather than segregation the
world has gone mad
there are dozens of examples that i
could share with with you and you often
say you say a lot of knows this and
you say we're not allowed we're not able
who's the people stopping the
conversation who are they
um
people let work at networks frankly like
the one i'm speaking on right now who
try and claim that you know it was it
was racist to investigate the lab leak
theory it was i mean who said that
but i'm just saying that when you say
allowed i just think it's a provocative
thing you say you say you say we're not
allowed to talk about these things but
they're all over the internet i can
google them i can find them everywhere
i've heard about every story you
mentioned so i'm just suggesting of
course people are allowed to cover
whatever they want to cover but you and
i both know and it would be delusional
to claim otherwise that touching your
finger to an increasing number of
subjects that have been deemed third
rail by the mainstream institutions and
increasingly by some of the tech
companies will lead to reputational
damage perhaps you losing your job
your children sometimes being demonized
as well and so what happens is a kind of
internal self-censorship this is
something that i saw over and over again
when i was at the new york times
this is this weasley kind of trick that
uh these people pull people like brian
stelter
where you've got barry weiss
describing the situation in our culture
it's undeniable if you're an honest and
rational person
all of that is obviously the case
and then he says what do you mean you're
not able you you're not allowed to say
these things
what do you mean i've i i hear people
say these things all the time i go
internet and find people making these
points what do you mean not allowed to
you're you're you're perfectly free
you're perfectly free to say any of
these things that you want
he says right as as there's a gun to
your head
like like a man coming in with putting a
gun to your head
telling you to do something and then
saying well you i mean
you're perfectly free to do what you
want
if you don't do what i want then i'm
going to shoot you but you're perfectly
free to do it
uh
that that's the trick they pull
it's just like when we say uh that
someone's been canceled
someone like barry weiss who has been
canceled
and then the response from the corporate
media
and their blackies is always what are
canceled i i've i can still find them
what do you mean canceled
no they still have a platform so they
might not have a platform on any of the
big tech but i could find them somewhere
on the internet if i looked for them
and look they did a fox news hit they're
not canceled
uh
yeah when we say cancelled we don't mean
that a person has been
physically killed although
eventually perhaps we'll get to that
point
but you've you when their job is taken
away
their reputation
has been left in tatters
they've been smeared
they've been lied about that's the point
so that's what brian stelter is saying
he's like saying yeah you know
if you don't agree with me
and with the system
we're gonna ruin your life
we're gonna take everything from you
we're gonna try to take anything
everything from you if we can
we're gonna try to get get you kicked
off of every single platform that we can
which is most of them
now uh but you'll still be alive at the
end of it so we haven't really taken
away your free speech or anything we
haven't we haven't really taken anything
from you and we certainly haven't taken
your power to choose
what a weasel uh
speaking of which from the daily wire
says democrat vice president camilla
harris is set to deliver a video message
to congregates in about in more than 300
black churches across virginia urging
them to vote for democrat gubernatorial
candidate terry mcauliffe in november's
election
um
cnn first reported the story noting that
the video message would go out between
sunday and election day
and we have so this is a video message
again that's going to be played in
churches in black churches in virginia
and let's uh
let's first listen to the message and
then we'll talk about it
terry mcauliffe has a long track record
of getting things done
for the people of virginia
when he was governor in the wake of the
recession you'll remember
he brought 200 000 jobs to virginia
incomes went up and unemployment went
down in every city and county in the
state
and now terry mcauliffe is stepping up
again
with a clear vision about how to rebuild
virginia's economy for the future
to raise the minimum wage
to make health care more affordable
to give every child
a world-class education
virginians
you deserve a leader who has a vision of
what is possible
and the experience
to realize that vision
huh
okay so this was i wanted to play a part
of that
i want to play part of that because
obviously i hate myself and i want to
subject myself to that punishment and
you as well
but also we want to hear is is this
really an explicit
are they finding a way to get around the
irs uh rules here or or is this an
explicit endorsement explicit
campaigning
by the vice president in a church
for a candidate and it's the latter i
mean this is explicit vote for this guy
type of stuff well
byron york uh of the washington examiner
he helpfully tweets this out
from the irs
here are their rules for this kind of
thing
and it says under the irs code uh all
irc section 501 c3 organizations
including churches and religious
organizations are absolutely prohibited
from directly or indirectly
participating in or intervening in any
political campaign on behalf of
any candidate for elective public office
contributions to political campaign
funds or public statements of position
made by or on behalf of the organization
in favor of any candidate for public
office clearly violate the prohibition
against political campaign activity
violation of this of this prohibition
may result in denial or revocation of
tax-exempt status and the imposition of
an excise tax
pretty clear there
this is directly intervening for a
political candidate
that's what's happening here
now say what you want about
these irs rules
uh
pro or con
that's what the rules are
and we damn sure know
that if something like this was
happening in the reverse on behalf of
conservatives the the or republican
candidate by a conservative
politician you know the cries would be
would be
deafening
uh from the left to have the irs go
after
that church and everybody involved in it
that's not gonna happen in this case
though because
you know we we live
as we have reviewed we live in a lawless
country
and all of these laws
none of them apply to everybody
especially when it comes to the irs
maybe maybe the irs will will surprise
me though with their in
integrity i can't even say without
laughing maybe they'll surprise with
their integrity and their in their uh
consistency
and actually go after these
churches and camille harris
you know we'll see i really i really
don't have my hopes up
um here's someone who does have
integrity though this is a nice this is
a nice pallet cleanser here a state
trooper in washington say even though
it's a sad story in many ways it's also
inspiring as this is somebody
who who will do the right thing we've
talked about uh you know the
cowards who sit back and are afraid to
intervene or afraid to do the right
thing afraid to take a risk
then you have people on the extreme
other end of that spectrum who are
willing to risk everything give up
everything that was the case for a state
trooper in washington state
who left the job over vaccine mandates
and we have here his final sign off
and his message especially for the
governor of the state let's listen
this is my final sign off after 22 years
of serving the citizens of the state of
washington
being asked to leave because i am dirty
numerous fatalities
injuries i've worked sick i've played
sick
we've buried lots of friends over these
years i'd like to thank you guys i'd
like to thank the um
citizens of yakima county as well as my
fellow officers within the valley
without you guys i would have been very
successful and you've kept me safe and
got me home my family every night
um
thank you for that
um
i wish i could say more but um this is
it so
state 1034 this is the last time you'll
hear me in a state patrol car
and jay ansley can kiss my
very well said uh
especially at the end there
and
it's a
it's a it's a sad story like i said it's
also inspiring that there are people
i mean this is no
obviously this is no small thing to give
up your job your livelihood something
that you've poured
20 years of your life into
um
that's a that's a real sacrifice
you know these days we're so used to
seeing people celebrated
for taking political and ideological
stands
and then when you look you see that
they're not risking anything they're not
putting anything on the line
right
very different situation here
but it really worries me also
this is why the vaccine mandates among
public officials police officers
especially
in the military you know
the vaccine mandates there
worry me
more than maybe anywhere else
because it's an infringement on liberty
obviously
but also because this is one more thing
kind of
smoking out the good people
the people with integrity
because no matter where you stand on
vaccines it doesn't matter
uh
you you could be fully in favor of the
vaccine you could think the cover
vaccine is the greatest thing ever
and this this particular trooper i don't
know where he stands on it
on the on the issue of the vaccine
itself that's doesn't even make a
difference
this is about this is about opposing
tyranny
so
uh with vaccine mandates in law
enforcement and in the military
and you see people who are doing things
like this and they're stepping down
they're leaving
it's a very courageous thing to do
but it's one more thing
where we're driving out
the people in these positions who most
oppose tyranny and who have the most
integrity
and i'm not saying the people that
remain in the military or in law
enforcement have no
integrity okay i
and i can't we we have no vaccine
mandate
here at the daily wire as you've
probably heard
if there was one
no i can't sit here and say for sure
what would i give up my job would i give
up my livelihood i got four kids to
defeat
you you can't really know what you would
do in that situation until you're in it
and people who decide to stay in because
they got to take care of their family i
get that
but there are those who are willing to
go all the way who have who have above
average sort of courage and integrity
and so what we're doing is we're we're
we're driving all of them out
and given what these positions are
uh
that that's that's pretty struggling
who's gonna be left at the end
uh speaking of
people that remain in the military well
let me start with this a little context
this is from the new york post
not about our military but over in china
it says china tested a nuclear-capable
hypersonic missile in august that
circled the globe before speeding
towards its target the test shows china
has advanced space capability that
caught us intelligence by surprise
citing five people familiar with the
test the report said the chinese
military launched a rocket that carried
a hypersonic glide vehicle which flew
through low orbit space before cruising
toward its target
it missed the target by about two dozen
miles
but shows china's astounding progress on
hypersonic weapons
the us russia and china have all been
working on hypersonic weapons russia
tested one such missile in july the u.s
plans to outfit all the navy's
destroyers with these missiles which can
travel five times faster than the speed
of sound
so according to the report china has
these hypersonic missiles that are
nuclear capable and so those can fly in
low earth orbit you know around the
globe and then land on their target or
at least get you know even 24 miles away
if it's a nuclear weapon that's close
enough to inflict uh
massive karma carnage obviously so
china's doing that
supposedly u.s officials were stunned
and surprised by they did they didn't
see it coming i don't know if that's
true or not but it wouldn't surprise me
and what's our military up to at least
the people who are are leading our
military
well here's a tweet from who is this
this is this is major general joe
clybourn
um
and she tweeted
over the weekend a picture of of herself
at her desk
shoes off feet up on the desk
and she's got the pedicure
toenails there that you can see
and
she tweets she says
why the army thinks a french manicure is
an obnoxious color compared to the
civilian world which views it as an
understated yet professional look is
beyond me but i have to be in uniform
tomorrow so here we are it looked nice
while it lasted
i mean
all you can do all you can do is laugh
about it i don't know what the other
option is besides weeping openly on
camera which i can't do
um
although maybe if i did they'd make me a
general in the army at this point
while while while china's testing
nuclear hypersonic missiles we've got a
major general tweeting complaints
about the fact that she can't have the
nail the nail color that she wants when
she's on the job
not a great argument i got to tell you
she's not representing female leadership
in the military very well here
so there was uh there were there were
people making this point and
righteously and rightfully mocking her
for this
major general
tweeting complains because she can't
have a french manicure when she's when
she's on the job
she was getting mocked for this and she
finally responded to all the mockery
with a series of tweets she says
number one i'm a woman actually she
wrote i'm a women
w-m-e-n
which maybe she does identify as
multiple women you never know these days
she says i'm a woman in the army get
over it two i worry and take daily
action on a lot of things including
prioritizing our soldiers and airmen
three i have a professional civilian
career i balance with military
obligations and a lot of god in country
time like 700 000 other reserve
component troops
for if you think we'd lose a war because
women are in the army or wear nail
polish wake up
rethink what excluding 51 percent of the
population does to our national strategy
especially when only 1 in 10 are able to
serve women earned their place
rightfully to wear our great nation's
uniform no major general
it's not that we're going to lose a war
because of nail polish we're going to
lose a war because of you and people
like you
totally incompetent
focused on all the wrong things
while you have china claiming global
dominance and
securing the ability to annihilate our
cities
you're focused on your nail color that's
why we're going to lose a war
not because of the nails just so you
understand
all right finally daniel craig was on a
serious xm radio show where he uh
explained why apparently he goes to gay
he says he's not gay but he goes to gay
bars
and i was just kind of scratching my
head over this here's the ants here's
here's why he says he goes to gay bars
instead of uh you know straight bars
let's listen
i've been going to gay bars
for as long as i can remember and one of
the reasons
because
i don't get into fights in game
that often right no no
yeah no we didn't get into a fight that
night and um
because
the aggressive swinging in right
heterobars
i just got very sick of as as a as a kid
because it was like i
i just i don't want to get i don't want
to end up leaving in a punch-up and i
did i mean that would happen quite a lot
right and
it would just be a good place to go
everybody was chilled everybody you
didn't really have to sort of state your
sexuality it was okay
and it was a very safe place to be and i
could meet girls there because there
were a lot of girls right there for the
exactly the same reason right i was
there right so i was it was kind of you
know it was an ulterior like
oh i bet there was an ontario motive
daniel craig
this
this to me sounds like
uh desperate rationalization
yeah i i mean i don't know but that's
what it's that that's how i that's how i
read it here
it sounds like you know someone saw him
in the gay bar and he's saying oh no no
i i no i i go to the gay bar because
if i go to the those other bars i'm
gonna beating people up
i can't go into a bar without getting
into a fight i got women swarming me i
said you know
no i just go to the gay bar because
i don't want to have to get into fights
and also i get i get way more chicks at
the gay bar man
uh okay what what bars are you going to
daniel craig
you know you're not you're not actually
james bond you know that right
so what bars are you going to you can't
walk into a non-gay bar without getting
into a fight
i don't know i mean maybe i'm maybe i'm
just going to i'm going to the right
bars maybe the wrong ones i don't know i
kind of want to go to these other
bars that daniel craig is talking about
where you walk in there as soon as you
walk in the door you know you give the
you show your id to the bouncer and then
just someone punches you in the face
right away just the fight starts right
away
been in many bars of my time i've never
been in a single fist fight at a bar i
think i've seen like one maybe
i don't know
i don't know if i buy it daniel craig
but
that's your own concern i suppose
let's now read the comments
who's rocking polka dots without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
this is from em she says lizzo is the
perfect example of the emperor isn't
wearing clothes
yeah a bunch of people comments made
that connection about uh
lizzo wearing a see-through dress
to cardi b's birthday party
uh completely nude under underneath and
you know i was talking about how
everyone pretends that it's this
beautiful site when
nobody really thinks that and i i don't
know how i didn't i don't know how i
didn't make that connection that was a
failure on my part this this is
literally the emperor wears no nuke uh
no clothes
that's what this is that
that parable brought to life
is what liza was doing there
walking around basically naked and and
of course i knew they're going to do
this they put the picture up
you know what but that's that's a
beautiful sight i'm told
put the picture up again put it up again
actually
for everyone
that's
beautiful
if you don't find that beautiful then
you are
a bigot
and probably a racist
that's what i'm told anyway okay you can
take it off
uh travis says lizzo's dress clearly
draws inspiration from a whale being
caught up in a fishing net
travis
once again every once in a while someone
leaves a comment
in the um
that i find personally offensive
we don't make jokes like that on this
show
certainly no fat shaming not going to be
allowed
that is not
that is not funny travis you're banned
from the show
how dare you sir
um
let's see
sort of the same says my husband and i
would be divorced today if he had stayed
home for two months or more or or more
after every one of our four children had
been born he was needed at work but i
had everything under control at home a
week might have might have been nice
especially since i had four high-risk
pregnancies but more than a week would
have driven me crazy today we are in our
60s and he works from home and things
are fine because i don't have to worry
about taking care of a newborn
and my husband
but i want to jump ahead because this is
what our daily cancellation is going to
deal with but
yeah as we talked about paternity leave
briefly on the show on friday
uh i i i do i do also have this question
i mean all these and i've heard and
we'll get into this in a minute but
heard from a lot of guys over the over
the weekend
um and women too talking about the kind
of paternity leave that they get or
their husbands get
there's one person that told me that
there is a woman said that her husband
got four months
four months of paternity leave
for their first child so there were no
other children
so
four months
for one baby
what the hell are you doing for four
months
for two parents to take care of one baby
and if you if you need that like if you
need
two parents home 24 7 to take care of
one
immobile baby
how are you going to function once that
baby gets older and if you have a second
kid you're doomed
well yeah i'm jumping ahead like i said
we'll get that later
scott says matt you've missed something
in the pc box checking for tolkien's new
film as of last year those boxes must be
checked if the film is going to be
considered for certain awards i do agree
with you ever in solidarity with you and
the spg i would be boycotting the film
uh yeah i wouldn't even call it a
boycott i'm not even saying i'm gonna
boycott the hobbit it's not a matter of
boycott it's just simply i have no
interest
in it i mean a boy a boycott is a real
boycott an effective boycott
is where
you're a potential customer
and you actually want to use the good or
the service or whatever it is
but you're choosing not to because
you're trying to make you're trying to
send a message or make some sort of
point
what i'm saying is i simply have no
interest
minute the pc box checking starts and
you're right that the academy's made of
these rules now where if you want to be
eligible for words you have to do this
uh giving even more incentive
but whatever's behind it the moment i
see that i i have no interest it it
takes me out of the story
and so it's not it's not a hard decision
for me to make
uh
alexander says they have to put music
behind the advertisement to make it seem
like matt is sincere and not at all
internally making fun of it ha ha
i don't know i don't know what you mean
i love all i love and cherish all of our
sponsors
let me tell you something even if they
didn't pay me
to advertise
their products i still would
that's how deeply i love all of our
sponsors
don't take that literally sponsors you
still have to pay me
uh dan says matt is atheism dead it
seems like the new atheist movement is
dead at least
wouldn't you say
uh yeah this is this is kind of a weird
thing that i that i've been hearing a
lot recently
from uh from some christians that uh
atheism is dead or the new atheism
movement is dead
those are two different things by the
way there's atheism then there's the
so-called new atheist movement and that
was back you know 15 years ago it
started with uh
with
sam harris and richard dawkins and
christopher hitchens and those guys and
they all they all put out these anti-god
books all in the span of like five years
and they were the whatever they call the
four horsemen of atheism or something
and it became and it was called the new
atheist movement and and that's dead i
mean that's gone
um
and you don't you don't see atheist
books being released
every every month we went through a
period where it seemed like
12 times a year there was another
atheist book coming out talking about
how god is and doesn't exist and all
this kind of stuff
so you don't see that anymore does that
mean that atheism is dead no not at all
i think that that's uh that's a nice
fantasy that's a nice bedtime story that
maybe we as christians like to tell
ourselves we can sleep easy at night but
i don't think it's true at all
in
fact you could look at this from the
other direction entirely
and say that it's actually in some ways
a bad sign that we don't have all these
atheists who are out arguing for atheism
anymore and they're not releasing books
all the time
it's a bad sign perhaps
because it's not needed
okay that
before they were trying to
you know uh
undermine subvert
what they considered to be a religious
culture
although at the time when they were
doing this we were not actually a
religious culture even then but that's
how they saw it
now i think you kind of look around and
you say well this
it's already a godless secular culture
what is there to argue for
no reason to put out an atheist book and
most the people already agree
or or maybe even worse they just they
don't care
vast majority of people in our culture
today probably don't really care that
much about the question
which is even worse situation to be in
so that's that's probably how i would
take it
not that they've lost but perhaps as it
stands right now they've kind of won
because we live in a we live in a
secular culture
if you're looking for the for the uh
silver lining you came to the wrong
place
you know when i was a little kid gift
giving occasions were pretty easy
because people would like my parents
would spend a lot of money buying me
gifts and all i had to do was just draw
something on a piece of paper and give
it to them and they would pretend that
it was the most amazing and beautiful
thing they've ever seen i can't get away
with that anymore i mean i couldn't i
could just scribble something on a piece
of paper and hand it to my parents on
you know for christmas or something like
that uh it probably would not get the
same reaction which is why i defer now
to the professionals at
paintyourlife.com
you can get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price or you can
combine photos of people or places you
love into one painting this makes a
great gift
for your loved ones it also is a great
gift for yourself if you're looking for
something to put up in your own home and
it's fast you can receive your portrait
in as little as two weeks when uh when
i've gone through this i was the first
time i was shocked by how quickly
um they get the painting done
but the quickness does not mean that
we're sacrificing quality at all because
these are beautiful paintings and again
you can send any picture of yourself of
your children family anything and they
will they will paint it and they'll make
it into a cherished and very meaningful
gift
for you at paintyourlife.com there's no
risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer get twenty percent off your
painting that's right twenty percent off
and free shipping to get the special
offer text the word matt to sixty four
thousand that's matt to sixty four
thousand text matt to sixty four
thousand paint your life celebrate the
moments that matter most also if you
missed uh sunday special this weekend
then i highly recommend you check it out
ben will be joined by none other than
barry weiss we just heard from her
during the
five headlines she's a brilliant writer
journalist and now the voice of her own
excellent podcast called honestly with
barry weiss they sit down to make sense
of all that's going on in the world
today and it's truly worthless and so go
check it out this sunday at
dailywire.com or on ben's youtube
channel ben shapiro dailywire members
get access to special bonus content from
sunday special episodes so don't miss
out join daily wire today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so it's time for another reverse
cancellation the outrage mob
pulled up in their clown car again and
spent yet another weekend screaming at
me online this time they were upset
very very upset i should say
about some comments that i made about
paternity leave
now
uh
of all of all the times that these you
know gabbling hyenas have tried to
cancel me i have to say this is this is
maybe one of the weirdest times so for a
little background last last week as we
discussed on the show it was revealed
that transportation secretary pete
boudege has been on paternity leave for
two months after adopting twin twins
with his husband
um while he was gone
the nation descended into a supply chain
crisis with cargo ships log jammed in
u.s ports and store shelves empty as we
head into the holiday season
buddhija decided that that would be a
good time to take an eight-week paid
vacation
now let's be very careful here not to
suggest
that the situation would be better if
buddha judge was around it wouldn't be
he's incompetent and useless and
unqualified for every job he's ever had
if even if he was around he'd only be
staring at the problem impotently or
else he'd be dutifully working to make
it worse
so nobody is begging buddha jizz to come
back to work and save us
we're merely pointing out that in
principle the guy who heads up the
department of transportation should not
disappear for two months while the
country faces the worst
transportation related crisis in decades
crisis or no crisis though
it's absurd for any public employee paid
on tax paradigm
to be given that much time off
now you can make an argument for women
on maternity leave but not for men
paternity leave is a nice luxury for
private companies that can afford it the
us government is not a private company
it's a public institution deeply in debt
failing in just about every way and
everywhere
so this is not a time and not the place
for those kinds of luxuries
but that's that's the somewhat safer
point to make right
you already much more hazardous place
you are in more hazardous waters
when you go away from that
and instead you start saying mildly
critical things about paternity leave in
general as a concept
and that's what i discovered when i
tweeted this on friday i said the thing
about paternity leave is that there
isn't much for dad to do when the baby
is a newborn especially if mom is
breastfeeding his main role is to take
care of mom as she recovers but of
course that doesn't apply to buddha jij
who is
so i'm not sure why he needs paternity
leave at all
that's what i said
and that was enough to provoke three
days of sustained outrage
here is yet another thing
that you could say to almost any group
of people in real life and everybody
would just nod their heads but if you
make the same common sense observation
in front of the left-wing internet rage
mob
they'll be sent into demonic
vomitus spasms
so over the weekend thousands and
thousands of people many of them
verified accounts media personalities
and so on have fluttered around
screeching like bats yelling at me that
i'm a deadbeat dad i'm a terrible
husband i'm a sexist i'm a monster i'm a
super villain how dare you how could you
wait what are we mad about again
and yet amid all of the howling and
squawking
none of these shrieking banshees have
bothered to explain how or why i was
actually wrong about what i said
notice i did not say that
nobody should ever have any kind of
paternity leave
if you work for a private company
they can do what they want
i took off three or four days for my
kids if you want to call that paternity
leave that's fine
i also didn't say that there's nothing
at all for a man to do for his family
after a child is born i said that as far
as caring for the newborn himself
most of that is going to be done by the
mother
she in most cases will be feeding the
child
the child also needs and wants his
mother's presence his mother's touch her
voice
the father should be interacting with
the baby also obviously but the infant
is far more focused on his mother at
that age
and needs his mother more
there is no mother in the buddha jij
household but that doesn't change the
point here
babies need their mothers
which is why two men shouldn't be
allowed to adopt babies in the first
place
and the outrage mob can now start a
secondary campaign over that comment
but i'll say it again two men should not
be allowed to adopt babies
because babies need mothers
they also need fathers which is why two
women shouldn't be allowed either
but in a normal situation
there is a mom and a dad
and in those early stages
the mom is the star of the show as far
as the baby is concerned the dad plays
more of an auxiliary role post birth as
i said his most important role is to
care for his his wife who has just
performed the physically taxing act of
childbirth there's nothing controversial
about this or there shouldn't be
it's just how things work and it's fine
it's funny that so many people have
shouted at me tears in their eyes
insisting that no you know there's a lot
for the man to do for the baby
and then and then they and then they
list those things and they say oh you
could change diapers he could give
bottles he could rock the baby to sleep
one guy mark signer who's a lawyer and
an author
he uh tweeted at me he's one of the many
white knights who who uh wrote in to um
you know let all the women know that
that i'm a bad guy but but but they're
not bad
and he uh he said that you know he
unlike myself he's a great dad and he's
a wonderful husband
um and after his child was born he was
very involved this is what he tweeted he
said
one of the ludicrous one of the most
ludicrous tweets i've read in my life
this takes the cake as the looniest
not sure what kind of dad matt walsh is
but i'll take my version 24 7 singing
reading cuddling bottle feeding to two
newborn twins
and i'm sure glad that pete boudija is
doing the same
but 24 7 singing and cuddling
something tells me that was a bit of an
exaggeration i hope for his wife's sake
that it was
but you see how he makes my point for me
accidentally singing reading cuddling
in other words not a lot
okay these are not time-consuming tasks
these are not tasks that you need to
take two months off of work to perform
these are mostly things that dad can do
and should do while still working to
provide for his family
i read to my kids every night every
single day i read to my kids and i also
work if i were to list the tasks that i
must perform for my kids who are now
older between the ages of two and eight
it would be much more extensive in fact
i could hardly list the tax the tasks at
all
as the job of parenting older kids is so
all-encompassing
newborns are immobile
they sleep like 18 hours a day
they have only two basic physical needs
sleep and eat
so if they're crying it's because they
want to do one of those things or
because they need to be burped
and this is why newborns are so much
easier especially for dads
and i have never in my life met an
actual flesh and blood human being in
real life who would disagree with that
assessment i mean this is something that
as parents we talk about all the time
with other parents
what what's the hardest phase of
parenting what's the most difficult time
you know to be a parent
nobody ever says newborn no one says
that
unless all they have is a newborn
talk to any parent with kids who are
i don't know
two or older
none of them are gonna say that the
newborn face is the hardest
none
and this is why the whole concept of
paternity leave makes no sense
if the idea is to give dad's time off so
that they so they can care for their
kids and bond with them
why would the leave kick in right after
birth when most of the dad involved care
and bonding will happen later
infancy is precisely when there is the
least for the dad to do
and the least opportunity for bonding i
didn't say none and no
the least
so why isn't anybody advocating for uh
paternity leave that starts with a
child's first birthday let's say
the answer to that question is also the
answer to why
everyone got mad at me in the first
place
and also why the left feels so strongly
about
paternity leave i mean keep in mind
the people now claiming that this is
absolutely critical for both mom and dad
to be home immediately after birth
will also insist that both mom and dad
can go to work in a few months and have
nannies and daycare centers raise their
kids and there will be no detrimental
effects at all
so like for the first month or two of
the baby's birth
you've got all these left to say oh so
we gotta have both parents hopes it's so
important so important
and then you ship the kids off to
daycare for the rest of their childhoods
and we're supposed to believe that
that's perfectly fine
i mean if if i were to say
that um that more women should consider
staying home
permanently with their kids so that
their kids are not raised by strangers
i'd be called a sexist
and yet if i raise a complaint about
paternity leave not even a complaint but
a but a mild criticism
and so it's a horrible thing because kid
those babies they need both parents
there
what do you think the needs end at two
months you idiots
what do you think happens at two months
that's so magical
we've got to have the oh yeah
buddha juju's kids they they uh
they they they need bootage there for
two for two months
after that yeah who cares
throw you know
throw them out in the woods and let the
squirrels raise them
since when do these people give a damn
about parents being involved with their
kids at all i mean they they think
parents are domestic terrorists just for
showing up to school board meetings for
god's sake
so
since when do they care
well the answer is this
the answer is sex differences
okay
that's what explains this weird reaction
namely their denial of sex differences
their problem with my position on
paternity leave is that i am
acknowledging the inherent differences
between mother and father
that's it
that's what it comes down to
that i would dare suggest
that there is a difference between mom
and dad
and that kids
interact
with mom and dad differently
and that they need different things from
mom and dad
and that god forbid mom and dad have
different roles in a child's life
for me to suggest that is
beyond the pale
that that is the that is the the thing
you're not allowed to say
that is the unmentionable right
so that's what it all comes down to
that's what they're actually upset about
they don't care about parents
taking care of their kids they think
parents are totally expendable
they think that they think the
government school system should start
raising the kids by the age of three
no
the only thing they care about is
denying that there is any difference
between the sexes
but as much as they want to deny it it
is true
the dad plays a different role
just as important
ultimately but different
and so when i talk about dads going to
work
and you know what i've heard from the
left all weekend is oh so you're saying
dad should be a deadbeat
they shouldn't do anything for their
kids
no
you idiots
working for your family and providing
for them is not nothing
so
i was home for i don't know like i said
a few days after my kids were born then
i went to work
and i made money which i brought home to
them
to put a roof over their head and to
buffoon their mouths that's not nothing
that's an important role
it's not exactly the same role that my
wife plays
it's different
and that's okay
that's good
okay
and you're all canceled
uh so i'm glad we got that
out of the way now
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day
[Music]
godspeed matt walsh show is produced by
sean hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the transportation secretary remains
missing in action on
paternity leave inflation hits a 13-year
high and a major airline ditches its
vaccine mandate check it out on the
michael knowles show